program on metagenomics we're going to
be
starting now so this omex logic
metagenomics program is focused on
bioinformatics
for the study of microbiome using
next generation sequencing this session
is
a first session we'll do an overview of
the program
uh give you some idea of what topics
will be covered in
interactive sessions like this one today
we'll also discuss the different other
resources that you will have access to
during this program that includes some
online course material
that you can complete on your own time
as well as
coding exercises and some practical
exercises using the big data analysis
platform t-bioinfo but before we jump
into that
let me tell you a little bit more about
these kinds of
omixlogic programs and about
our team
so the omix logic programs are a result
of an amazing effort and collaboration
between
pine biotech which is an innovative big
data analytics company based in the us
as well as numerous institutions that
have participated
in content evaluation curriculum
adaptation and project proposals
as a result the omics logic programs
have been thoroughly tested
and are proven to lead to excellent
outcomes for both students and faculty
that are interested in bioinformatics
or the application of data science to
biological
and biomedical research
for those that are joining us for the
first time my name is elia brodsky i'm
the co-founder and ceo of pine biotech
our company's vision is to enhance human
health and well-being by enabling
biological research and discovery
with relevant data big data analytics
solutions
and support our mission is to simplify
bioinformatics and advance research
through our modular and
intuitive multiplex analysis platform
powered by human experience and
artificial intelligence
we are offered training research support
and big data analytics tools
designed for research and biomedical
discovery and our mission is to support
cutting-edge research projects and solve
big data challenges
by making our solutions easy to use and
to provide training for those interested
to use them in an effective way
to arrive at sound and represent
reproducible results
i am honored to have been working with a
large team of people that have
much more experience in this area than
myself including some of the other
co-founders
dr alfred tauber and dr lena nabrodsky
together they have designed and
developed an innovative system
that allows us to conduct such programs
and is supported by a team of experts in
bioinformatics
computer science and other areas
that help us form organize
and run programs like these
so omics logic metagenomics is a program
that is starting today on august 31st
and it is designed to be equally
rewarding to both students and
researchers
it does not require any background in
bioinformatics itself
and it is especially suited for
project-based learning
on a flexible schedule the program will
cover
main aspects of metagenomic sequencing
analysis of
16s ribosomal rna and other aspects of
micro
microbiology research utilizing
bioinformatics
tools and databases
at the end of this program participants
will be conducting independent or group
projects
analyzing data from the public domain
and learning from
high impact biomedical publications on
the microbiome
so to introduce the program the
resources
materials and the schedule we'll take a
look
at what microbiome is and
how you will be able to learn about
bioinformatics for
microbiome research in the next
few weeks
so since the discovery of the microscope
humans have been learning about
microorganisms that surround us
and as the resolution improved more and
more representatives of the unseen world
have
been discovered the scale of optical
resolution can reveal details of up to
one micrometer which is a typical size
of bacteria
today microscopes are tremendously
powerful allowing humans to see
smaller and smaller elements that reveal
how the world of microorganisms
functions on every imaginable surface
and is actively interacting with each
other
in this image you can see a super high
resolution image
achieved with helium ion technology that
shows the process of bacteriophages
in green attack the e coli bacteria
so the e coli is blue and the green
are the bacteriophages
the connection between disease and
microorganisms
has been established in the 1800s and
already towards the end of the 19th
century
laboratory methods for growing
microorganisms in a lab culture were
developed
helping characterize them with staining
these studies provided important
information about bacterial function
in isolation however it was soon
apparent that most microorganisms live
in complex communities today we know
that the microorganisms or the
microbiota
that make up the human microbiome are
not just unicellular
organisms living alongside each other
but instead form a highly regulated
structurally and functionally organized
communities
attached to surfaces as biofilms with
inter-species collaborations as well as
antagonisms that contribute to
ecological stability of these
communities
the stability of these communities is
fascinating as many of us probably know
from trying to battle such common skin
conditions
as dryness eczema or acne
they form distinct communities and these
microorganisms
are interconnected and determined to
maintain
their community bacteria within a
biofilm
can communicate with each other by
producing detecting
and responding to small diffusible
signal molecules in a process called
quorum sensing which confirms benefit
for host colonization
biofilm formation defense against
competitors
and adaptation to changes in the micro
environment
quorum sensing activities in biofilms
are also involved in the virulence and
pathogenic potential of bacteria
and are therefore an important factor in
understanding and controlling bacterial
infections
as they enable microorganisms in
biofilms to become more tolerant
or host defense and antimicrobial agents
inside each community you will find that
there is a variety of
compositions and different types of
bacterias that are dominant
providing some insight into their
functionality
but also giving us a better
understanding of these community
changes as we study different types of
conditions the human microbiota
is estimated to be 10 to the 13th to 10
to the 14th of microbial cells
with around one to one microbial cells
to human cells ratio
even though it was previously reported
that there is a much greater number of
microorganisms these figures have been
updated by sander and all in 2016.
these numbers are derived from the total
bacterial cells in the colon
the organ that harbors the densest
number of microbes
however each one of these microorganisms
carries
important functional properties in genes
that contain
genomic information and can give insight
into their functionality
these properties and the genomic
information about microorganisms have
been
of a growing interest to the scientific
community resulting in a total
over 80 000 publications
the majority of these studies have been
focused on the intestinal microbiome
but since the 1990s microbiome studies
were significantly advanced through such
major initiatives as the metagenomics of
the human intestinal
tract and the subsequent human
microbiome project
these are very large studies that have
been made possible through the advances
in metagenomic sequencing
as a result skin lung gut and even brain
microbiota is starting to be
characterized
and better understood to reveal
important relationships between
the microbiome composition different
types of species
of microbes and conditions and their
onset
in the humans
so many of these questions can be
answered using
two types of technologies that we will
review in this program
primarily we will be focused on next
generation sequencing
next generation sequencing allows us to
study the composition
or specific genomes and genes that are
being expressed
by microorganisms it can also be studied
using mass spectrometry mass
spectrometry is a technology that allows
us to
capture portions or whole proteins
and metabolites allowing us to
understand
what are the specific products of gene
expression
and signaling between these bacterial
organisms between these microorganisms
our primary study in this program is
going to be on metagenomics
so metagenomics is different from other
types of omics data
because genomics proteomics and
transcriptomics all focus
on the whole of a single organism so for
example we want to study
all of the genes or proteins that are
expressed
in a given organism or we want to
understand variation of dna
across cells of an individual
but metagenomics is the study of
the composition or the whole
community of particular microorganisms
so it allows us to study these
communities not
individually but as a part of this
larger community
i hope that in this program we will be
able to learn about the microbiome
and its function which includes
differentiation of the immune system
food digestion and nutrition energy
generation and conservation
metabolic regulation processing of
environmental chemicals
maintenance of skin and mucosal barrier
function
and prevention of invasion by pathogens
so it really does affect
a lot of areas of human health
pre-clinical
and clinical conditions as well as
treatments
oh sorry okay so
in this program we will utilize several
different resources that i want to
review
in this session the first one is we will
have
a series of interactive sessions just
like today we'll get to the interactive
part
in just a little bit but i want to make
sure that all of you have received
the invitation to this session obviously
you have if you're on the session
but you will also receive regular emails
from
marketing at pine dot bio so it's
important to add that email to your
address list to your contact list
so that you will receive these
invitations regularly and we will do
this
uh on a pre-determined schedule and
afterwards
when we will have project review
sessions we'll also
send you custom invitations for that as
well
the second part that we will review
today are some asynchronous courses
that are found on our learning platform
so we will review that in just a second
you know many of these courses you will
see assignments and these assignments
leverage
our analytical platform as well as some
additional resources
that we will cover today as well so you
should have received
with the email about this session your
passwords for the access
to these different platforms so in the
next few slides
we'll review how to access and utilize
those in this program
okay so let's first make sure that you
have the login information
for server.t bio.info
and edu that t-bio.info
how do you know that you have access
so the first thing that you can go to is
this page
once you get to this page please let me
know that you're there
by answering yes in the chat box or
you can write yes i'm there
got it something so i know that you've
arrived at this page and you see what i
see
did anyone get here all right great
shreya is here
all right great so those of you that are
registered in the program
will have access to everything that i
see
[Music]
some of you already know from some of
their previous programs
so i assume you already know most of
what we are going to discuss today
in terms of access all right great
so a few important places that you will
find
these are specific resources for this
program you will have a
forum where we will post information
about
upcoming sessions recording from the
previous session
we'll have forms as well as different
links for additional resources
on this tab you will find courses
related to this program
we'll have some project examples we'll
be
keeping progress record for all of the
participants of the program so we'll
review some of this progress
and make sure that all of the challenges
in terms of technical challenges are
being
addressed and also you will find here
under menu the syllabus tab
so if you go to the syllabus tab you
will see an overview
of all of the sessions that we will
cover and some associated resources
for each one of our sessions so please
make sure that you can
navigate to all of these links and you
can see the information if you
have not yet completed your registration
you can also complete your registration
and if you have any trouble completing
the registration you can
reach out to marketing at pine.bio and
we'll help make sure that you have the
right links
and can complete your registration
the first thing that you can do is you
can
start with the course called
introduction
to bioinformatics introduction to
bioinformatics
is not related directly to metagenomics
but it also helps us to get to learn
about you
so this program is to learn about
microbiome and metagenomic sequencing
but also helps us
if we understand your background and
your interests
so we can best adapt our material
throughout the sessions
to make it more most effective for you
so if you go to this introduction to
bioinformatics course
this is a free course so anyone can
actually take it
one of the first lectures that you will
see is intro survey
so in the survey if you fill it out we
will receive this information and will
help us
make sure that information is for
is available on all of the participants
and we can make the most of this program
together
[Music]
okay so for this particular
survey in this course everyone should be
able to have access
it's free you don't not need to be a
participant of this program
specifically okay so please take a
moment
and fill out the survey if you have
filled out the survey
previously you should see your
information already here
after you have completed this survey and
went through this course which i think
is going to be informative
even if you have a little bit of
background in bioinformatics already
you will also understand how the system
works and then there are several courses
and i've seen that some of you have
already started taking some of the
courses which is great
which are introduction to metagenomics
metagenomics 1 and metagenomics 2.
so in these courses we'll review some of
the same topics that we will cover in
the interactive sessions
but we will add additional depth and
additional project examples in the
interactive sessions that we will have
each one of the courses is organized in
the following way
you have here expectations so it's
important to understand the terminology
and the biological context
as well as different types of data
formats and analysis logic that we will
explore
during this whole session or this
program
we'll try to utilize some aspects of
topic mapping so that it's clear why are
we applying
specific data analysis methods to a
particular type of data
and what are the specific outcomes of
that analysis that we're interested to
take away to be able to interpret some
biological phenomena
based on our analysis results
you also see a number of different
tutorials
and multimedia elements that help
explain
different types of data sets and
projects these are going to require some
additional reading
in many cases so that you understand the
project as a whole
and have significant background in that
project before we start the data
analysis part
in the analysis section we will utilize
some practical analytical steps and
these practical analytical steps are
organized in some kind of a logic
so once you have understood the logic we
will also
look at some practical assignments that
will in
if you are interested in going that far
utilize some coding elements in r in
python
so we will discuss some exercises that
will help you make the most
and be able to improve some of the
visualization
outputs and also ask some specific
questions from the data set that we
do the analysis for and so to
keep track of all of these kinds of
activities
we have developed a number of tools that
help both us but also for you
understand that your progress as
compared to the rest of the group
and spot any challenges that you might
be facing
so for example we can see when you
run a particular pipeline we can also
take a look at the outputs of that
pipeline to make sure that you've gotten
results
and address any issues that come up
there are different
coding exercises that we will review
together and to make sure that
everything is set up since we don't have
access to your computer
we have created this online interactive
platform
that allows us to also see that you have
completed everything
without the need of installing different
libraries and resolving any kinds of
technical issues that typically arise
during installation and we don't have
access
to monitor that so in the online courses
specifically for
metagenomics you will see that we cover
a number of different
pipelines pipelines are connections
between
different executable scripts and
algorithms
that process data in a step-by-step
manner so here you can see an example of
one of the lessons
where the data to bioinformatics
workflow
is reviewed so we'll do a number of
review sessions
on these types of pipelines discuss the
specific steps
why these steps are necessary and what
types of outputs do they produce
so that you can continue and explore the
data
in a more different in a more detailed
way
okay so since i've seen that some of you
have
already uh done some of the preliminary
coursework
i wanted to ask a few questions and that
will also give us some sense of where
you are so
it's okay if you don't know some of
these answers
but if you do know some of these answers
you can
put your answers in the chat box after i
ask each question and then we can just
briefly review
what the answers are and we'll continue
to do such reviews
in our future sessions so the first
question is
which of the following terms is
unrelated to 16s
ribosomal rna
okay so here we have a few people
answering
protoplasm
all right excellent so many of you
already know the answer
let's review why that is protoplasm so
can someone
tell us what is protoplasm
okay so jd deb is saying cytoplasm and
organelles
so what is protoplasm
okay so
okay it's the cytoplasm equivalent of
plant cells
excellent so protoplasm is the complex
semi-fluid translucent substance that
constitutes the interior matter of a
living cell and
is composed of proteins fats and other
molecules suspended in water
it includes the cytoplasm the nucleus
and eukaryotes and organelles such as
mitochondria
so this does not have anything to do
with 16s ribosomal rna why
because 16s ribosomal rna is
the gene of the ribosome
that could be used to study microbial
microbial taxonomy
and the other terms in the answer here
amplicon is sequencing that amplifies
16s ribosomal rna or one of the
hypervariable regions
next generation sequencing is what we
use to study the 16s ribosomal learning
gene
phylogeny is our representation of
taxonomy that we can look at for
different
compositions of the microbial
communities
and hypervariable is a term of a
particular region in the 16s ribosomal
rna gene
that allow us to understand the
taxonomic composition
of a particular community okay so
this is a question that helps us study
some of the
terminology okay so what is taxonomic
classification
taxonomic classification can best be
described as
one studies of increased rates of
disease within a collection of
microorganisms
two new ways of simultaneously
sequencing multiple
genomes three studying the extent to
which genetics sequence the
sequences diverge four a way of
preparing genomic material to be
sequenced or five
the removal of variable regions of rna
to increase experimental
validity okay i'll just give
a few seconds here
all right excellent so all of you are
familiar with taxonomy
it is uh studying the extent
to which genetic sequences diverge
which is which allows
us to understand how they form different
groups
okay and finally shotgun sequencing is
an important technique in metagenomic
studies which of the following are
true regarding this type of sequencing
number
one shotgun sequencing is based on
multiple reads
two utilizes a reference genome that is
compared to the sequence reads
three can be performed on dna and rna or
four all of the above
all right excellent so all of you i see
have a lot of background information
already
on metagenomics taxonomic classification
is a way to study metagenomic
communities
and we use shotgun sequencing so it's
important to understand
some terminology related to what this
technique
actually does so it's really good to see
that the majority of you
have some background in these topics for
those of you that do not
i recommend taking the introduction to
metagenomics course
and that will give you a lot of
information about all of this
terminology
and for those of you that know but need
a refresher
that's also a good way to evaluate how
much you remember
so to analyze this kind of data as i
mentioned
initially you do not have to have any
background in coding in fact we will use
a
point and click interface to understand
the logic of analysis
and this logic of analysis will clarify
why we are taking certain steps and what
is the objective for each
input and output in this process
so these are going to be called
bioinformatics pipelines
for those of you that are already
familiar with bioinformatics pipelines
we will actually take a look at some of
the settings and the options that allow
us to study
the data and extract different types of
outputs from this data
we will also then later on go into
the specifics the specific code that
allows us to run these different steps
and see what kind of variation we can
work with using coding
so let's make sure that you have access
to this platform so the link is server
dot t dot
and please let me know once you are here
okay so the link
this is the link
all right great so for those of you that
are
here first of all if you are logged in
you should see your profile
details right here for those of you that
have registered for the program already
you should have gotten an email
with your access details so you will
have your name and your password in the
email
there are several different levels for
those of you that are
interested in using this platform
there's a demo
level and this is the fastest option
right and i want to stress that
if you want to just understand how
different types of methods are used
and what are these bioinformatics
pipelines you do not have to run
any kind of analysis so for example you
can go
into this demo
read about a particular section
and then just run a simple
pipeline that will not take up
any of the server resources
and provide you with an output that you
can still discuss
in the context of a course so for
example
i have here a completed pipeline and
several outputs that i can click on to
download and explore
you can get this kind of access for a
demo for free
so even those of you that are not a part
of the program but you would like to
understand
how these different types of pipelines
work you can request
free access and you will be able to run
these kinds of demos
to request that kind of access you click
right here
and you will see a form this form will
be sent over to us and we will email you
the details
the second level is an educational level
so for education you can run any kind of
public domain
data sets we will review this in the
context of the program
but it's important to understand that
either this data set is going to be
provided to you so specific links to
data sets are going to be sent over to
you with an explanation of what to do
you can find those in the lessons
in the coursework that we have discussed
or you can find them from public domain
data sets
like ncbi
so on ncbi you can search and find
specific data sets
and then we will tell you how to use
those data sets in the analysis
the final level is research when you
have
access to a research account you will
have an ftp account where you can upload
data sets of your own
from your lab or from uh you know
wherever you
have those data sets stored and actually
reference those data sets
on this big data cloud-based platform
what's important to remember is that
there are several places where you will
constantly kind of refer to and look
for example you can see previously
completed pipelines
that you can always go back to and look
at what the
output was and how you got to that
output you will also see a report on
each one of your pipelines right here
also you will go back and you can go
into
all of the different sections and for
understanding of what these sections do
you can actually hover over these eye
icons to make sure that you know
what the section does inside a
particular
section as i mentioned once you are
using the educational version you will
have to
select some inputs
and in those inputs
in those inputs you will determine
what types of pipelines are possible
okay and this is a great time for
questions so if you have any questions
related to what we've discussed up until
now please put them in the chat
for example shreya is asking if i don't
have a data set from research how can i
get an experience
of data analysis so as i mentioned
inside the course work you will get some
data sets they will be
given to you you can also and we will
discuss this
even today you can also start looking
for data sets on
public repositories like the national
center for biotechnology information
so for example here and we'll discuss
what types of data sets are going to be
available for what if you click on
microbiome you will see a variety of
different data sets available for free
these are publicly accessible databases
that you can get experience of data
analysis with
does that answer a question sharay
great
yes and for prana i will definitely show
the results of a pipeline and how to
interpret
and understand the outputs that will be
the topic of our next session in our
next session we will start looking at
what types of next generation
sequencing data sets there are what
types
of pipelines you run to analyze them and
what would be the outputs
and obviously for outputs there will be
a variety
of different types of outputs and we
will discuss
how to interpret the different types of
outputs
okay parameter does that answer your
question
okay and this meter yes we will
definitely we have suggestions for
uh books today we will review
three different articles that i think
you can start with
one of them is a chapter from a book and
that chapter
talks about microbiome research and some
typical
uh methods of analysis that you have to
learn about so we'll do that at the end
of today's session
to get started i recommend some of the
coursework that i already mentioned
where you can both read about practice
and evaluate your understanding using
quizzes and assignments
okay thank you deepak if anyone else has
any questions about this i'm happy to
answer about
the resources that we've covered but i
have a few more that i want to get to
towards the next part of this
presentation
[Music]
so again just a brief overview of this
platform
you will find multiple sections for
sequence analysis for example we will be
relying on next generation sequencing
data to study
meta genomics you will see that inside
you have some demo pipelines that you
can click on this drop down
and see the inputs outputs and what the
steps are to analyze specific types of
data
in our future sections we'll talk about
data mining
and how to use machine learning and some
utilities that will be
useful for this type of data and you'll
also
be able to go back and see all of your
running
and past pipelines so you don't have to
open a pipeline and wait for it to
finish
you can leave you will then get a
notification that your pipeline finished
and return to see what are the outputs
that you are getting
and obviously to check that you have
your
profile and you're logged in you can
always go to your profile
okay so another question here from
sultan mohidi
metagenomics is applied to all organisms
if i want to study on some organism and
the data is not available on ncbi
then how to proceed with the research
unfortunately
if you don't have data it's hard to
study something not being able to
generate that data set yourself
so we will try to focus on uh
specifically microbial or microbiome
research
where we can find publicly available
data sets
if you're interested in other topics and
there are no data sets
available on that topic you will either
have to generate that data set
or potentially that research is not
possible
yes so definitely you have to generate
the data
if you are interested to apply
bioinformatics to study that thing
okay so what are some of the sections
that we will review
the first section that we'll talk about
is the metagenomics microbiome section
that allows us to
map reads onto reference databases
look at outputs that tell us what are
the specific
uh taxonomic operational taxonomic units
or even
full 16s ribosomal rna genes
that are present in a database then we
will turn to
analysis of 16s amplicon data where
specific hypervariable regions are
amplified
and then standard tools for analysis of
composition
species richness and diversity
can be applied to the data set and
visualized
using different types of graphs in
charts
to practice some of these methods we
will also
use some coding and analysis overview
using the code.omicslogic.com platform
okay so let me just show you an example
if you go to
code.omicslogic.com
okay you will get access to different
courses
sequentially you have to log in
using the same email address that you
have used to register for the program
so first of all
you will get you will not
see what i am seeing you will see a
landing page and you have to register or
log in so
when you do that use the same email
address
once you log in you will say you will
see
some of these types of tutorials so
please let me know
once you see what i see on the screen
and um okay let me answer the questions
in the meantime please
yes tell me yes once you've gotten to
this page
for adarsh what are other specific
databases for microbiome alone
so there are some 16s ribosomal rna gene
reference databases like silva green
gene
um and others rdp there are also
different projects that we will review
today
for example the human microbiome project
so we'll take a look at those today
in this session
okay so adarsh and mohammed does that
let me know that answers your question
and muhammad your other question how can
you get the course for free
you're welcome to join uh the
introduction to metagenomics is a free
course so you're welcome to
enroll in that course okay did anyone
else get to this page
i'm gonna wait until um okay great
at least five people um get access to
here
so we have all right excellent so here
you will see some
basic introductory materials that you
can
already take a look at for each one
you will see that there's an exercise in
both r and python
so you can already start exploring how
to do some of these basic things
what we will do um
okay so what we will do here for those
of you that are registered
is we will review such packages as
microbiome
phyloseek including some methods of
analysis like
nmds pcoa
and svd so those of you that are
registered for the program
we will do a little bit of coding and
this is only if you're interested in
uh so you don't actually have to do uh
programming if you don't want to if you
want to you have some
options here we will mostly rely on
r for this program for other programs
we do python is also useful as well but
in this case we will primarily work on
r
okay and for those of you that need
some introduction i hear some
introduction to data science
again specifically yes and i will
explain the points here in a few minutes
so specifically the packages that you
would want to install
are microbiome filo seek
and you can also explore kai
and also
[Music]
mother
how can you find this page it is code
dot omixlogic
and then for those of you that are just
starting
you can go to about and here you will
find
some guides on
using this system so this is
essentially an r server um you can
see that the analysis works on the
server and produces results that you can
take the results with you'll have some
explanation and then
try some things yourself by changing
some of the code
and running that code for example i can
copy this link change this link right
here
press on run and you can see success
running code
and it shows me what i got so there's
actually
no no
uh installations that are needed and for
gregory
yes i will get to that um in our future
sessions
but today i'm just doing an overview of
the different types of things that we
are
going to review but we will review both
time and mother
okay so take a look and play around with
this um after you complete
uh this whole uh session section you
will
start getting points okay so what are
points
we have a particular syllabus
this syllabus includes completion of
courses for example here's a course
once you go through all of the lessons
of the course
sometimes quizzes and assignments you
have to press
on finish course and once that course is
finished
you will see that you get a certificate
for each course let me give you an
example
so here's a participant from another
program that we have
um you can see her badge
um yes you you can
yeah you don't have to read through
everything but you
have to submit all of the assignments
and quizzes to get
the results so here you can see uh
this person has almost 20
000 points and these 20
000 points have been a result of this
kind of activity for example
she completed coding steps she ran some
pipelines on the server platform
she completed some uh course work
and you can see over here under
courses although and this is true for
all of your
um different uh profiles you will see
how once your course is completed it
will say completed right here
so you'll see all of this you also will
see certificates
so for each one of your courses you get
a certificate of completion
for an individual course
once you have completed that course it
looks for both
points assignments and quizzes to
generate this kind
of certificate now yeah so you can see
all of the different certificates you
also get a certificate for the program
itself
the goal of this type of a profile
is to both track progress
address any challenges and questions but
also for you to take away and build up
your profile
you can look at some of the top profiles
over here
okay and i will pause again for
questions to address
all of your questions so please continue
to post your questions
um on the chat so once they get there
you will see that we will address all of
those so you can see here some of the
top
profiles uh you will learn you can learn
about
them and we will also hope to see all of
you
in this list so you can see that it goes
for quite a long time and you have to
reach at least
11 000 points to get to this list okay
so what are some of the things that we
will talk about we have some basic
courses and you will see also that there
will be tracking of
progress as you make your way through
these courses
and specifically we will look at
how to study and visualize
results of the big data analysis
pipelines
how to study composition of your samples
and look at some of the popular packages
that typically are used in microbiome
studies
so these are some of the things that we
will cover and most of them
as you can see on the screen are going
to be
in r okay so let me
address some of these questions so what
are the specific databases i think we
answered that
um uh you need this
so can can we talk about otu tables and
how do we
yes so we will talk about that yes
definitely
do you need to download them um again
yes
if you want to continue and use this for
your research obviously it's going to be
useful for you to have that package
already installed there's some guide
guidance on how to
install r and python if you want to we
will send you the link
um which os will be better any os
would work windows mac linux
whichever one you prefer is fine there
are some challenges associated with each
one so
we will try to help you address any of
those but we also provide the
cloud platform so that we can avoid
getting stuck on the specific
installations and understand what we're
trying to do
um okay how to make svls through
ftp for sana we will send you
a video on how to do that and then if
you have any
challenges with that we can schedule a
session to discuss
okay so let's review how are we going to
cover all of this material in this
program because we're obviously not
going to have
all of the time in each one session
to cover all of these different aspects
of data analysis
yes and all of these sessions are going
to be recorded
and sent to all of the participants of
the program
for this specific session this is a free
session so we will be posting it on
youtube
and if you follow our youtube channel
beeps and maybe you could
put a link to our youtube channel that
channel will be
um where we will have this video
okay so you can see an overview of all
of the different sections or all the
different sessions sorry that we will
have on this link
yeah i'm just going to show you where
this link is
to the syllabus
okay great so here
you can see what we will cover in each
session
for example here we are doing an
overview of the entire course
the tools and resources for the program
what are some of the expectations and
schedule
and some of the important deadlines so
if you scroll through here you can see
that we are starting on august
31st and then we will go through
september 2nd
4th 7th 9th
11th and 14th
and so that will be the end of our
theoretical part of the program the
objective
is to get you to start thinking about a
project proposal or a research question
and where to find the right data so for
muhammad
and adarsh and others that have been
asking what are the specific data sets
and
how to do that kind of analysis that is
where we will get to by september 14th
it will take us some time but we will
review
types of sequencing types of data
types of analysis pipelines what are
some example
projects and then we will start looking
for those projects and also think
how do you actually plan for and
structure your analysis
so that the project that you have
developed could both be
completed in a short period of time
you understand the significance and can
communicate
the significance of this project to
other participants of this program
so your goal is to do this by september
14th
so you have some time but we will review
you can already start thinking about it
and i will give you some
guidance today on how to get started
with that as well
okay and i see that there are a lot of
questions so are there any other
questions
about what we discussed discussed so far
so again
yes we will work on an independent
project
the deadlines uh september 14th is when
you have to submit your project proposal
up until then you can work on that
project proposal
there are some course material that you
have to complete there's a certain
number of
points and that's the last point i'll
make about how the points work
you actually have to get to either an
independent project
complete completion or 10 000 points to
get a certificate of excellence
for all the other participants that have
done at least a minimum
of the basic courses which are three
courses
introduction to metagenomics
metagenomics one
and metatronomics ii those will get a
certificate
of participation for the program
are there any other questions how long
is the project proposal
we will actually review what the project
proposal is
it is not very long it is similar to a
the objective of the project
is to be similar to a post or
presentation
at the end of the program but when you
say how long
i think that it's only a few paragraphs
the project proposal is just a few
paragraphs
publications uh gregory please clarify
what do you mean by publications
well at the end i will give some
reference publications for you to start
reading on
at the end of this session
if that's what you meant
all right so let's review the schedule a
little bit so you have a
clarity on what each section will be
dedicated to
so first of all we will talk about
uh if results become publishable there's
no agreement so whatever
research you do is yours our goal is to
support you
in what you do for the duration of this
program
okay so to study
different types of communities and their
composition we will talk about
sequencing methods and approaches to
generate data
so that we understand how to generate
the right kind of analysis and how to
develop an
understanding of what that analysis
means
akil if you haven't used any programming
tools
you can complete this course yes without
yeah you don't need any programming
background
and omixlogic code will be an optional
portion of the program
it is very simple to follow so even if
you don't know
any coding you don't have to do any
installation
and you will be able to complete all of
this independently
or with our help we will actually review
any challenges that you might have
in our interactive sessions and uh help
you out with that
[Music]
the full program is not free you are
correct
um the majority of the people in this
session today are already
participants if you have not completed
registration
beeps could potentially send you a link
for
completing your registration
and thank you dr sultan mahadeen i'm
very very pleased with your comments
thank you very much
okay so in our uh next session
uh september 2nd we will talk about
metagenomics so you again for those of
you that are already familiar with
metagenomic sequencing
uh we you don't have to join but
this is something that will give us a
review um and to come
to prepare for that session we have this
online course
introduction to metagenomics
how do you know that you need to take
that introduction to metagenomics if you
found it challenging some of the
questions that we discussed in the
beginning when i was asking you
different questions
you know that you probably should review
that course if you felt like you know
everything and you understand the
differences between these
terms and their meaning you probably
don't have to
take that course so then we will talk
about how does the microbiome actually
function how do we understand what is
the functional impact
of a community and there are different
strategies
using different databases we can
understand taxonomic composition
but also we can talk about what is the
impact or association
with a particular condition so we'll
talk about on september 4th
then we'll talk about the variability in
composition what are some of the methods
that we have
to analyze and look at particular
members of those communities that
probably have a dominance
or a difference between multiple
conditions
okay so for muhammad yes
the the full course the full program is
not free you are correct
and uh gregory if you i'm more of a
biochemist molecular biologist not a
statistician what background resources
do i have for understanding the
statistics
so in each one of these sections in each
one of these courses
we do discuss the analytical steps
that are needed to take to process data
and
analyze the data and in the interactive
sessions for example this session on
september 7th
is going to be focused on the
statistical analysis
and what are the statistical outputs
that are meaningful
to do biological interpretation so i
think
that both of these aspects that
coursework
the practical analysis and interactive
sessions
should give you a good understanding of
some of the statistical methods and
their meaning
okay nadars i will get to your point
here in a few minutes as well
so then we'll go through some examples
for example the american gut
is a project that was started in the
beginning of the human microbiome
project
and it was a collection from citizens
to contribute to a study
of microbial diversity in
normal healthy and self-reported
conditions so we'll actually take a look
at that data set
and try to understand how do we see some
of that variation
how do we interpret it and how do we
find associations so it's a very
practical aspect of understanding
microbial diversity
in the context of human health
thank you very much gregory
another part of microbial impact or
functionality
is actually an indirect one so
it is not typically suspected that
microbiome itself has an association
with other types of uh for example
um neurological type function
so one is a direct one for example you
can think
of uh sensitivity of the gut
and ability to process different foods
or even
impact on treatment for example
immunotherapy
those could be fairly clearly and
directly explained
by looking at microbial composition
however some conditions like anxiety
are fairly difficult to link to
microbial diversity and so we will take
a look at one of these projects
that does show how we can separate
diet and other types of confounding
factors
from the direct impact of the microbiome
and look at a project
example where we can find such
associations
and test them experimentally of course
but we will use
a published study to look at that kind
of a connection
and speak about the gut brain access in
general
which i think is a very fascinating uh
kind of a research direction that we can
explore and potentially you could
further on study in your independent
project
so then i think when you think about
your independent project it is very
important to understand
what types of data sets are available
what
types of data should you be looking for
but also how to
structure your question in such a way
that you can
ask a question and know what you will
get as a result of your analysis
so that you can make a clear and
effective
annotation and explanation of the
results
so we will actually take a look at how
to identify
a significant and impactful question
how to then find the right data set how
to
apply the right type of analysis and
produce the right type of visualization
that clearly explains both what you did
and
the results from a scientific
perspective
what do they actually mean so we'll have
a discussion about that and hopefully by
that time
you will have some examples so as i
mentioned september 14th
you will already have submitted some
project proposals
that we can look at in detail and even
practice some presentation
of what might be the result of your
analysis
then you will have another couple of
weeks to
get some feedback on your project so the
goal is not just to prepare a project
proposal
but to be able to conduct the analysis
yourself
present your research results and then
get some feedback both from
the program participants and by the way
you can work with
other program participants together you
don't have to work on your own
you always will find that there's a mix
of people who are more experienced on
the data and analysis side
more experience on the biological
interpretation side
or maybe better presenters than yourself
and so you can always think of these
projects
as a collaborative effort and your goal
is to get some expert feedback so
potentially if your results are then
publishable and you feel like you have
the time and the dedication to take it
to that level
we also offer research support after
that through our research fellowship
program
at the end of the program let me show
you a few
practical examples and talk about what
are we going to cover
as we discuss these project examples
so when we talk about the american gut
project
we're talking about finding associations
between
self-reported and some general
aspects of microbiome composition based
on a microbial sample so here's a result
from the american gut sample for example
where you can look at the different
types of bacteria present
in your sample compared to some averages
by different types you can see some of
the most abundant microbes
and we will learn about how to conduct
such analysis how do we take
one participant and see them in the
context of everybody else or compare
groups
and based on what types of so-called
phenotypes that are self-reported so we
can actually
look at that project right here
humanfoodproject.com american gut
as i mentioned we will also take a look
at projects that have some
indirect associations between the
microbial community for example the gut
or the fecal microbiome and
general state for example anxiety
is a psychological condition so what
might be the
relationship between the two and so
we'll see how
the specific experimental design and
different types of data that are
available in the project
as a whole can help us study that kind
of microbial variation
now when we talk about microbes and
metagenomics as well
you will see that the term metagenomics
also is used
to talk about sequencing of genomes or
of particular representatives of this
microbial community
so we'll also look at how we can apply
metagenomic sequences to study such
examples of tuberculosis with a which is
a mycobacterium
ebola which is a virus or rhizobacteria
which is
an important type or a class of
microorganisms
that can have a huge impact on crop
production
other types of exciting research
opportunities
using microbial data and using
metagenomics
include the study of treatment impact so
how effective
is treatment for example when we talk
about
different types of um
different types of probiotics when we
talk about
different types of treatments that are
going through the system for example
through the gut the absorption of those
elements
is also impacted on through the
microbiome
and how treatment with antibiotics can
actually lead to
deregulation of the microbiome
communities
and have a long-term significance for
different types of risks
it is important that these types of
studies have actually led
to very practical results already for
example you can see here an article that
was published on november 5th
in 2018 that talks about the china
chinese government approving alzheimer's
treatment that targets the microbiome so
we we can actually see very practical
outcomes that have come from such
research
you can also see that kind of in the
future of
microbial research this type of
study can have a significance
on treatment selection and today we
look at treatment selection that is
treatment of clinical conditions
as well as pre-clinical conditions so
different types of sensitivities
and different types of diets that
contribute to overall health benefits
ideally in the context of this program
you will see how
different types of omics data could be
analyzed
using bioinformatics analysis pipelines
and reference databases to understand
the relationships between
clinical and omix data for applications
of diagnostic
assays and selection of therapeutics or
even an
understanding of some basic questions
about the impact of
microbiome on the human health
so about your independent projects for
independent projects we have and for
interaction um
for interaction and once again i get i
will get to the questions here in a
second
for the interaction between all of you
between yourselves and our team which
will
support you we have a forum so again if
we go back to this page
uh please take a moment to go to the
forum link
so i'll just paste this link in the chat
you will see here already several things
that have been posted
welcome to the forum session recordings
this is where you will find all of the
recordings from these types of sessions
like we're having today
questions about the educational courses
so if you have any questions about the
metagenomics coursework that we are
going through
you can post them here questions about
the pipelines
so the pipelines that are not going as
fast as you think they should be
or you're getting some errors or not
getting the right kinds of outputs you
can post them right here
when you post those questions or those
comments
please add the link to your pipeline
what is the link to your pipeline
if i go into this pipeline you can see
that
up on top here i have a link
so this is a url that has a pipeline id
and using that pipeline id it's very
easy to understand
what is the challenge that you're facing
using our back end
administrative panel where all of the
script outputs and inputs are recorded
also on the forum just go back to the
forum here
you will see additional resources for
the program and so this is something
that you can take a look at
today i pasted here important
publications to get us started
for example bioinformatics for the human
micro microbiome project
human microbiome project overview and
some basic concepts for microbiome
research
an example from brazil a microbiome
project from there
finally you will see a project
submission form
so in the project submission form you
will see
a form that is dynamic in other words it
updates every time that you change
something
and this is directly related to some of
your questions before
how long is that project proposal so
this is your project proposal
you will see all of your information
from the form that hopefully you will
fill out today right here and then you
will also
start filling out these project sections
so the project sections include project
title
problem statement or what are you trying
to solve
project summary and this could be
several paragraphs long
linked to the raw data so what kind of
data have you found for this
and then some reference publications
do you get a protocol that guides you to
create a pipeline perform analysis step
by step yes
you do and most of that will be found
inside the coursework but we will also
review that
in our interactive sessions for
gregory's question
multi-omics will you be learning how to
integrate across omics
not specifically in this case but we do
have a whole section on multi-omics
integration and we will touch on
association studies those association
studies will include
genome-wide association studies
association
between using statistical association of
feature-to-feature correlation
as well as some network analysis
that could be done for that kind of a
study
i think it will be more informative to
take a look at multinomics integration
in the context of a particular project
example so if you are interested in
multinomics integration i recommend
finding a project on a publicly
available resource for example
the ncbi database that has that kind of
data
okay so again the objective
of this particular section is to submit
a project proposal and to help you in
that process
we have a whole article that
talks about different examples
um let me just give you the right link
here
so we have here a series of
recommendations i'm sorry
this is the right link where you can
explore
some examples and some guidelines on how
to pre
prepare an impactful and interesting
project proposal
finally our objective is to really help
you transition
from what you learned in this program to
a
real research using bioinformatics tools
and methods and we have
quite a lot of experience with previous
participants of our programs
for example you can see olga udarzuba
here from
roswell park comprehensive cancer center
that was
a participant of an omics logic program
before
and was able to understand how
bioinformatics can be applied to
her cancer research as well as to
actually use some of the tools
in her pre-clinical studies and apply
even to cancer patient treatment so i
think that's an important
outcome that we are very dedicated to in
this program
and we hope that most of you are able to
actually
get this kind of a benefit from this
program of not only learning about
bioinformatics but
also applying that to your research
study and i think we have the support
as well as the tools that will help you
make that transition obviously we are
not
experts in everything and so we have a
panel of
external uh support of
mentors that will be evaluating projects
at the end
most of them come from our partners at
the tauber bioinformatics research
center this is a research center
that is located in israel at university
of haifa in israel
and they have a number of phd students
and postdoc
students that are doing research using
bioinformatics tools
and participate in large consortia
projects
using bioinformatics and so we invite
them to provide feedback
for some of the research projects that
will include some questions and
clarifications that you will have to
make
but also for the top projects that we
jointly
recognize as the most advanced projects
they will provide
some detailed feedback and an evaluation
score
for your project so hopefully you can
use that evaluation support as evidence
for the quality
and significance of the project that you
are planning we recognize that the
projects themselves can take
quite a long time to complete especially
if they're real research questions
nothing nothing goes as planned
in any kind of research including wet
lab research or bioinformatics research
playing around with the data and
reanalyzing the data
and making your presentations multiple
times is something that should be
expected
and i'm sure that most of you are
familiar with that process
and some of it might be frustrating but
really it is
a beneficial process for
real impactful and reproducible results
so to summarize we have six
interactive sessions that are going to
be focused on some theoretical aspects
and practical aspects of metagenomic
research
during these sessions we will discuss
and review
specific questions data sets project
examples
and interpretation approaches for
microbial
data after that you will have some time
to work on an independent project so for
those of you that have
already registered we will have sessions
on these dates
it was all it will always be between 10
am and 11 30 am cst
central uh central standard time
during these sessions we will answer any
questions
and also provide you additional
information at the end of that
and post some responses on any questions
that you might have
does the access to omixlogic code expire
along with this course can i utilize it
in the future also
yes you can definitely utilize it
there's a separate license that you can
purchase after the program at a
discounted price
and use our online server for r
python code actually loads into your
browser session
so you can actually um utilize that
on your own computer
the zoom link uh yes at the same time
i believe it is the same zoom link uh
beeps that can confirm that
uh but you will actually receive an
email invitation
um maybe 24 hours before each session
that you can confirm and add it to your
calendar
so the objective of this program is to
understand the microbiome
to understand metagenomic sequencing
to understand methods of metagenomic
sequence analysis
and apply that to interpret the
microbiome so that will include some
methods
of analysis visualization and
interpretation
okay so how can you register pizza if
you are
here please reply some of these uh
technical questions
yes you can use any kind of microbial
samples um so let me get to
our next um okay so for the questions
okay and lipsa gregory also had a
question about
whether the sessions will have the same
zoom link or will it be a different zoom
link
i believe it it will be different after
this session because this session was a
free session
for anyone to join and learn about the
program also
but later on we will actually send links
yes okay thank you
[Music]
okay any other questions about what we
um what we reviewed up until now
okay so in general i just wanted to
finish off with
a couple of additional points and
those are related to some of the
materials that you can start
learning from for our next session
there these are the publications that it
would be beneficial to
review bioinformatics for the human
microbiome project
so here you will find information
on the human microbiome projects and
what types of bioinformatics methods are
applied to what kinds of different types
of data sets
also there is a link to the nih
human microbiome project itself this is
a data set
that a lot of people will use in
different examples of how
tools work and this is good for
benchmarking and different types of
comparisons
and also it is good to do some uh
questions right so how can i
have some questions that can be answered
with
this type of analysis and sorry that
that is behind there but there's also
another paper bioinformatics for
microbial
research concept strategies and advances
which is actually
a uh whole chapter from a book
so these are some of the links
okay will today's webinar be available
because my audio was
grappled in the beginning yes the
webinars will be recorded or they
are recorded and they will be available
on our
youtube channel but also you should have
a link
that you should get an email about with
this particular recording
after this session is over
can i store my metagenomics data free of
cost at ncbi
yes ncbi does not charge for storing the
data
if you have a data to submit a data set
to submit
um you can go to ncbi
and go to submit right here
so the chat links are available right
now where are these links
available yes they are available on the
forum so if you go to the forum
as i mentioned there's a few different
categories for posts that post was
specifically
for project submission but here is a
section
additional resources for the program so
if you go here
this is it these are the links that i
just gave you
okay so it's great to have all of you
here um thank you for joining today
uh just in conclusion i want to mention
that we do
have a linkedin group that we invite you
to join
um as well as the facebook group um
here i'll just paste the links
for those as well we want to build a
community
of those that are learning about
bioinformatics and
are going to apply bioinformatics in
their research
we feel that we can exchange information
and
connect you to other experts as well
we have over 500 people in our linkedin
group
and some of them with some advanced
degrees and both background in academia
research and industry so i think it
would be
beneficial to link up with those and
also on facebook as well for those of
you that rely on that platform it's
called learning biomedical informatics
okay mikhail it's also great to see you
here again
um prana can you give an example of a
project data where we can understand how
to initiate the project
yes i feel that some of these example
links that i gave
are exactly that so you will see
in our um
sorry watch the chat box you will see
on our in the courses we actually take
examples from some of these practical
data sets so if you have enrolled in
metagenomics 1 or metagenomics 2
you will see two different examples
explained there
but also some of the links to the
publications should give you an idea of
what kinds of questions you could be
asking from these types of data sets
and okay so how to initiate the project
actually
that's a great question i feel like i
also
touched on that topic but maybe it
wasn't clear enough
this is an overview
so if you go to that link
you will see some outline of what you
can do
and how to find a topic and how to do
some literature research
how to develop your project so there's i
think a good overview right here
on all aspects uh including some
examples from previous participants
that you will find here at the end
all right great well thank you again all
for joining today
um if you have any additional questions
i recommend posting
on the forum and for those of you that
are joining not from the
not the first time for those of you that
have joined our programs before it's
great to see all you
all of you back if you are interested in
starting to work on your project and you
need some support from us
we'll be excited to work with you on
developing those projects and
making sure that you have all the
necessary tools to do that
and i'm looking forward to seeing you
again
on our next session so look out for
those emails please
try to complete the introduction to
bioinformatics course for our next
session
in that course there's a survey that
we're looking
uh to get to know you a little bit
better your background
and your interests and what are your
objectives from this program
so we'll be looking forward to that
information and
we're also going to be excited about uh
seeing all of you join our future
section
the sessions we'll talk about next
generation sequencing
some approaches and what you need to
understand
to make sure that the analysis that
you're planning
is uh impactful so
again we'll see you again next time take
care